can you tell
the story of the months that led up to
barry's assassination
what it what what what did you know what
did you sense
what did you think okay when i got up
prison i hadn't been out long
i was a watch eating breakfast and there
was ronald reagan's
face right in the television we have
absolute proof
that the communist sandinista government
is in the cocaine running business
and there was that fat lady the c2 126
on the runway would build it in and i
thought oh
god he had done it so i had heard
that barry might been working with him
so what mom working with
with the dea whoever yeah he did he is
he was no longer on our side you know
so uh can you clarify how you got that
from the
reagan making a statement about we've
heard okay there was his plane
there was a bearish plane and okay on
the way north we could stop in in
nicaragua and land on a military base or
on a a basis they used those crop
dusters and all
and refuel yeah and so that shorten our
trip would go further into the jungle
and come up and that was what
pablo escobar and ocho and him and they
had there was associates with the people
in
nicaragua so barry was if that plane
was there that means barry was feeding
the dea information
he was working with him at that time but
let me back up a little bit when
when i was flying and i told barry we
would we would refuel
in trains airplane the loads in police
where i had a spot up there
and then that's when the they told me we
can refuel in
in uh nicaragua and then you fly all the
way and barry couldn't believe it
he says all right but i wanted to land i
had a place in louisiana
for ten thousand dollars that i could
unload and
jerifin oldham was paid off and uh he
said no
no no i can't get caught in me in
arkansas
i said what do you mean you can't get
caught in maniac so you get caught
anywhere
he said i can't if it can't but it's
going to cost you fifty thousand dollars
every time my wheels touch the ground
why can you explain why he can't get he
said he was
he was hooked up with with him the very
top and he even said
i'm going to have dinner with the
governor tonight
that's at that time i mean arkansas mr
bill clinton
undoubtedly and it's a little like did
bill clinton did you give him any money
and i said no i never give the man any
money
but it was like the money that i had
went to grand cayman islands and i told
my lawyer
i never touched that money he said you
don't have to fondle it to be guilty
so so what i mean there's a lot of
conspiracy theories
around the relationship between pericle
and the clintons
absolutely what evidence do we have
well what would you say from your best
understanding
um of what was the relationship between
bill clinton
and barry seal barry said and he knew
that he couldn't get caught in me in
arkansas and when that movie was going
to come out be called mina
somebody stopped it i mean they stopped
it dead in the tracks for two or three
years and the producer even quit
you mean the american made with tom
cruise movie it wasn't it was going to
be called meena it's the name that was
written and produced in mina
and wait waiting on hillary to be
elected
they they would not let that movie out
and that movie was changed
drastically but to push back on that
that doesn't mean there's
truth there that means they were worried
about
the power of the conspiracy theory which
stuck
exactly i don't know i mean you know
some
some conspiracy theories just because
they're popular doesn't mean they're
true
and ones that uh but it also doesn't
mean they're not true
and there's ones that are not very
popular that could be true but that one
that one really stuck did you do i mean
what's your sense
well i paid one and a half million
dollars for barry to land at meena
arkansas
so i was pretty well assured that he
couldn't get caught
and i said well i can't get caught in
colombia we can't get caught in
nicaragua i guess we got a license
it's that we went for it so when you say
i can't get caught just to clarify
there's a there's a sense where this is
a safe place to land
yes like completely safe so you don't
think he was referring to some kind of
um you know
like my grandfather who fought in world
war
ii would talk about bullets can't hit
him
so it's almost like you know believing
he's taking that fifty thousand dollars
and giving it to somebody to somebody
and
barry was honest so he wasn't just
taking it from me because he was making
a million dollars he didn't care for the
fifty thousand
ah man
you